you
hi everyone is Jerry this is the game
between the great mikhail tall playing
on the white end and his trainer
alexander Coblentz this was a training
game played in 1957 this is regarded as
a highly complex masterpiece and is one
that I will only be scratching the
surface with when I visit a few of the
complex variations so the magician from
Riga kicks off this game with E for
Sicilian defense on board
open Sicilian
variation
Richter rouser attack and we have a case
of opposite sides castling in this one a
few things to know in position types of
this sort think time think peace
activity think initiative these are a
few of the factors that should in most
cases precede material if you experience
any anxiety at the thought of maybe
being down upon or to or peace in order
to pursue an attack against the enemy
King maybe this is a position type
that's not for you maybe
Knight b3 avoids the minor peace
exchange and the majors can now see some
Queen b6 f3 preparing a King side attack
pawn storm black is doing similar
gee for sure enough trip to d8 prepping
a central expansion white wants g5 so
the bishop gets out of the way with a
punch Queen c7 H 4 B 5 the knight is
kicked back and white continues to press
immediately engaging with blacks pawns
not prepping g6 with first h5
this is an instructive pawn sacrifice
this speeds up the opening up of the
position white is there engaging first
what does white get H takes G H 5
chop-chop lights down upon but white has
a completely open H file to work with
this is White's Avenue into the black
position the major pieces will operate
very well along the H file now Knight f6
the rook comes all the way back
sometimes you would want to keep open
that h1 square for the doubling of the
rooks but not here white would like
something a bit more timely let's say
namely to have the Queen act as the
leader in this battery looking for mates
on H a black reacts in the center this
is a typical idea meeting a flank attack
with a strike in the center and d5 not
only prevents this Queen h2 idea but is
looking to spark a chain reaction of
exchanges this would detract white from
pursuing this King side attack
white has no interest in having the
center open up and so plays d5 this is
giving away yet another pond to ensure
that the D file does not open up black
takes it with the night if black was
excited about losing they would take
with the Queen hands that's gonna hurt
so Knight takes e5 the Knights thrown
into a pin that's broken straight away
Queen to h2 million one threat
lack bolts looking for a safe haven on
e7 note that black should not try to get
clever here with the move Knight to d3
if the knight is captured yes this is
going to hurt team white but white has
another option if 93 is played King b1
and it's white who gets the last laugh
preparing still this main threat and
you're ready to take the bishop and only
then the knight so in the game after
Queen h2 its King to f8 Queen h8 follows
and black doesn't react in the best way
here in fact Queen to h8 is not
considered best but yeah in a complex
position there will be ups and downs and
we do experience we do experience a
little bit of that here Queen h8 is now
met with Knight - GA
black does better to play to e7
counterpunch against the Queen and she
would just have to fall back somewhere
along the H file there is no there would
be no worry if the black King went to e7
there would be no worry of Queen takes
pawn because of rook to GE and this
similar tactic would now be present with
Bishop takes bishop in the queen is
struck F from a different angle that's a
painful fork so Knight g8 is played
rook to h7 Queen on the eighth-ranked
rook on the seventh ranked white is kind
of going all-in with that white queen
you know this king if he's ever calling
for help yeah that Queen is just not
going to be around
to help out for defense she's all in
with this attack in right now
g7 struck at only one way to defend the
F pawn has to get out of the way so f5
it is Bishop h6 you know that rook
wasn't just attacking the pawn but
pinning the pond so what's white doing
with Bishop h6 attacking the pinned pawn
rook to d7 is there as defense and how
to get another piece attacking g7 it's a
defended three times its attacked three
times how to add a fourth attacker
if only the rook can jump over the
bishop Bishop takes b5 ok this Bishop
isn't just making a calm little move
like I'll just go here and then here
next no the bishop is coming out with
authority snipping upon throwing a punch
at the rook throwing another white piece
in blacks house yeah now rook g1 is
right around the corner and yeah g7 is
ready to collapse here
on pawn takes Bishop rook to g1 and this
is collapsing
pawn takes Bishop is already a mate and
one with rook takes and if the rip plays
up here to defend Knight takes pawn and
eventually the Queen one of the major
pieces will be pulled away from the
defense of g7 that night on b5 would be
striking at everything so
what does black do rook to f7 this is
where there are some interesting
variations very complex variations and
this is one that is worth noting for
sure the game move was rook to f7
however this queen has no great moves
right you can't take the knight you
can't take here with the Queen
successfully suppose the knight went to
g6 striking it the Queen
what would white have in reply to that
Knight to d4 would follow saying you
take my queen I'm gonna take your pawn
and soon take your Quinn okay black
could then say well hang on I'll go here
first but then there's this move Bishop
takes g7 rook takes g7 and a star move a
beautiful interference move one of the
most beautiful interference moves I've
seen and that is Bishop to d7
and this is interfering with Black's
defense of e6000
on Bishop takes Bishop that's gonna hurt
and on Queen takes bishop this is still
gonna hurt Queen takes Knight Queen
takes rook okay this isn't this isn't
winning this is still messy but the the
attack continues here just a couple of
the variations that may spring about if
Knight to g6 was played in this position
what did we have at this point we had
rook to f7 rook to g1 and yeah it's it's
a bit difficult to defend against that
g7 point what's what's played here we
have now the major pieces look at all
this attention placed on the g7 square
what follows night to d4 white needs to
bring some more pieces into the attack
if ever pawn takes Bishop this knight
springs into play and soon there's going
to be Knight takes bishop and after the
recapture the Queen is pulled away from
defense of g7 what did what follows here
black is trying to interfere with this
pressure against g7 note again you still
can't capture here because of nice -
matin - boom man that's gonna do it so
Knight to g4 is played
takes night so some pressure for the
moment is released on g7 Bishop to e5 is
now they're looking to defend and
there's some punches being thrown knight
c6 it's like tall treats his pieces as
if they're ponds in the sense that like
he never even moves backwards everything
is like forward forward forward forward
look at all of these pieces that are in
blacks house not a single one of blacks
pieces are in White's house impressive
after Knight to c6 we have Bishop takes
c3
and Bishop to e3 is looking to sneak
into the c5 square that shut down with
d4 and now we have rook to h1 do you see
the threat the threat here is to
sacrifice the Queen Queen takes Knight
just as an example pawn takes Bishop
would meet would be met with Queen takes
Knight and that's the ball game so
that's the threat after we have a
tripling up on the h-file the game
follows with rip to d7
and now Bishop to g5 this isn't best
this is one of the last variations I'd
like to touch on best is considered G
takes f looking to just chip away at the
the e6 pawn make this guy flinch one way
or the other or maybe capture him if
pawn takes Bishop this pawn is super
menacing and there's that white is
renewing this threat of capturing the
knight and then giving maid on h8 and
one other note is if they capture like
this there's then Bishop to c4 in fact
you could take the knight first and then
go into c4 with mate soon thereafter in
the game however we did not see G takes
f instead Bishop to g5 finally that
Bishop is captured and now we have
another piece there's like this
infatuation with that h6 Square it seems
every any what every one of whites
pieces wants to get 2h sex one way or
the other
first the bishop and now the rook
preparing a lateral move rook to f6 it's
just amazing to see that now every
single one of White's pieces are in
blacks camp the follow up here is d3 and
this is now completely winning for team
white there was one amazing way out for
black in this position instead of the
move d3 and this is the last variation
to no black could actually get away with
taking the night allowing rook to f6
Bishop h6 rook g7 chop chop check
and after rook takes rook black can get
away with an eventual perpetual check
it's a really stunning variation where
the Queen is caught in the corner the
black king is in the center no way to
get at him further in a timely way and
yeah right around the corner there will
soon be Queen he won Queen c3 with a
perpetual check that would be blacks way
out from this position to scoop up the
knight doesn't go for it in the game
instead d3 what follows his pawn takes
Bishop d2 check King d1 just hiding
behind that pond there's no black piece
that can kick came away Queen takes
Knight and now black crashes through
rook f6 width check rook f7 the rooks
now in a pin and because of it g7 is no
longer defended directly Queen g7 and
black already throws in the towel
there's it's already a mate in 9 from
this position
what else to do if you capture the rook
there's Bishop to h6 rook g7 and yeah
this is going to be very painful a
similar idea in the variation I showed
where there was a draw there's not a
draw here though because of this line
with the Queen now looking to sweep into
one of these two squares and yeah the
King is safe for just a move and that's
all white needs is just one move and the
King is the white king is safe and the
black king is is far from safe so in the
game how this did finish was rook to f7
and Queen to g7 and black resigns
there's nothing to do if King to a e8 we
would have rook takes f7 and there is
one check but the King can always weasel
away and find safety for at least one
move on b2 and yeah first we had a
tripling up on the H file and now we
have three wild pigs here on the seventh
that's gonna not end well for team black
but that's as far as it went
after Queen to g7 black ends up
resigning in this one and yeah what a
crazy complex masterpiece of a game this
was so anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this in the
comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I'll
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care bye
you